hockey uh this morning uh my wife is
sleeping in a bit
um
what thoughts here i'm gonna do these as
i think of different aspects of language
learning
one thing is i bought this book
here
in a korean bookstore
which i'm kind of going through it's a
beginner book
a couple of thoughts it's always good to
go over the same material using
different sources
if i were to go through a beginner book
that i had done before i don't think it
would penetrate because it's not you
you need that new refreshing stimulating
for the brain even if you're
combining that new with repetition but
to repeat the same books i think after a
while it doesn't penetrate that's one
thought and of course as i go through it
of course it's the same train station
buying vegetables
i don't know always the same routine i
wonder how many people actually
use these beginner books to go to the
train station or to go and buy
vegetables in a store i think they'd be
better off to just have a variety of
interesting subjects you're just trying
to get familiar with the language at
this point and anyway there'll be more
snippets later bye
variety is the spice of life i'm a
sucker for new books
um the one that i referred to earlier
is the one on the left
which is quite a good book but i'm
really enjoying too as something to read
when i've got only a few minutes uh
is this dictionary
which has uh probably can't see that but
it has the different terms it has the
career at least the chinese characters
the hanja which i really appreciate
and then it has
you probably can't see that has a little
sentence sample sentence which you can
read through so you do a page or two i
don't know how much of it sticks
but it's all part of variety i think
variety is very important in language
learning
uh uh just to describe how i vary things
i had my easy starter book there and now
i'm doing an article from radio free
chosen
and this is the second article i've been
linking here
and i can now finally hit you'll see
there's a lot of yellow words a lot of
words that i have to learn
but that's okay
and now i'm going to click on move the
remainder
to known
and so i don't know how many uh let's
i'll have a look at the statistics here
there's now 151
links there including the ones that i
just added
but i'm gonna be downloading this here
download audio
it's only about five minutes long but i
can listen to it a few times in the car
then i'm gonna read this again and
review the words again and so this way
i'm kind of varying the easy stuff with
the difficult stuff
one of the advantages for me in doing
this
kind of material is that it's political
economics it's about cuba and economic
reform in cuba
is that i can pick up a lot of
hanja chinese character
based words i'm on my way to hockey uh
this is our steam sweater we're the old
goats
you can see this goat here
with his mug of beer that's us
and now i'm gonna have to put all my
hockey gear which i store here
into my bag here
i'm gonna grab myself a hockey stick and
off i go and of course i'll be listening
to korean all the way
okay
now this is just
studying my korean
hi back in the office a couple of
thoughts kind of came to my mind one was
that someone asked you know how do you
find the time how do you make the time
well i finished playing hockey all the
guys went up to the queen's cross pub to
have a few beers and lunch
and they were even talking about the
very attractive waitress that's a major
attraction there at the pub
and i said no i went off to a japanese
restaurant and i studied my korean
that's the kind of sacrifice you have to
make if you want to fill in those
you know target hours every day
just another tip